[Music]
happy 2019 river babes I'm you're a
serpent loving hosts Lee Aguilera and
I'm so thrilled to be reuniting with all
of you for the first time in 34 long
Riverdale free days now it's a new year
Sweetwater Secrets is back and we're
celebrating it all with a live episode
basically this feels sweeter than a pack
of fizzle rocks you know without the
whole gargoyle king hallucinations now
this is your preview episode for Episode
309 chapter 44 no exit and today I'll be
treating you with my three clues about
the mid-season premiere and dishing
exclusive interview bites with cole
sprouse Vanessa Morgan and KJ app' it's
gonna be a good one River babe so get
pumped Plus as always during our live
episodes I'm gonna be answering a round
of your questions about what you're
gonna submit to me right now and I have
no idea what you're gonna say so I'm so
pumped tell me what you want to know and
I'll go through as many as I can by the
end of the episode we're already getting
in so many hi guys so glad you're here
watching live with me but first let's
refresh our memories of where we left
off by taking a look back at some of
your top hisses kisses comments and
theories from episode 3 Oh a chapter 43
outbreak now first up there were so many
combo comments that gave a lot of love
to the same two things ladies and gents
wrote kisses to Cheryl being a
protective girlfriend and super kisses
to JB we love a little badass and then
sister shook echoed those same thoughts
saying kisses to all the Shoni scenes
also jellybeans is like a mini Cheryl
they're both such badasses what can I
say my river babes love fierce females
and I fully support this obsession
continuing on with shipper thoughts
Victoria neva posted hisses Juno bug
head it's coming girl
don't you worry and Bree Frances added
anyone else ready a F for Veronica and
Reggie yeah I am and I also know who
else is ready a F for Veronica and
Reggie that would be Charles Melton and
guess what I just got off the phone with
Charles this morning like 20 minutes ago
and here's what he told me when I asked
him about the potential for a Reggie
Veronica
blossoming relationship hmm he said
quote Reggie support for Veronica does
not waver not one bit
I think Reggie likes Veronica and it's
because she's strong she's independent
she's very well-spoken and she's
assertive I think he really likes that
and he's kind of met his match with her
personality wise now next up y'all had a
lot of thoughts about our red paladin
and the fact that he's not a redhead
anymore
amber w28 commented Archie finally looks
like his dad I'm loving it yes Fred but
it makes me so sad for him dumb Archie
stop making people want to kill you and
just go to school do not even play music
anymore okay well I will say that very
question is addressed for a split second
in this week's episode so good job and
if you're wanting more Archie scoop well
then take a look at what KJ Appa told me
the end of the winter finale
Archie goes off on his own you guys his
hair what was it like for you to kind of
embrace your own true hair color for a
little bit it was weird
also just the process of having to go
back and forth because we don't really
shoot things in order it's kind of
gnarly but my hair is definitely like
bristle now for sure thanks it was nice
to get to see that Archie's not going
off totally alone he has a Vegas with
him what can you tease about what's
coming up next for him yeah I mean he
finds himself again in some weird kind
of predicaments in the woods and his in
his cabin that he's staying in goes
through some stuff I think for sure yeah
he comes out of it a lot stronger I
think and it gives him a lot of
perspective yeah Archie's journey in 309
is interesting that's all I'll say for
now moving on to your theories Luci mate
said my theory
Penelope brought Gigi to Riverdale as
she grew up in the sisters of quiet
Mercy Lucy I love that very nicely done
girl and Larina 83 is offering her own
take and said I think the gargoyle king
is Hermione
Penelope shot a glance over to her mind
right before she had her seizure also
has anyone else noticed that only the
females have seizures that also makes me
think that The Gargoyle King is a woman
and who else would be in the Pembroke
with Hyrum except for one of his family
members also Hyrum and Hermione were
arguing about the miscalculation that
led to the mass seizures at school which
included Veronica
Jane girl well done and I never noticed
that about only the females in Riverdale
having seizures so that's very
interesting and last but not least jazz
pandas added I don't know who the
gargoyle king is but I really hope it's
not a dad it would just be too much
repetition I couldn't agree more
first we hide Clifford blossom and then
we had Betty's dad if the gargoyle King
is Hiram
I think I'll scream it would just be so
damned bring it as of now it sort of
seems like this is all big Hiram's plan
I don't even know anymore but take a
look at what the always candid Cole
Sprouse had to say about all of this
this all has been a big dastardly plan
by Hyrum when you read that episode what
was your initial reaction did it make
sense to you does it ever makes sense I
mean isn't that the point like I think
every episode is supposed to feel so
outrageous that you go of course yes of
course it's this person of course you
know Hyrum is running a drug lab that
sells them as pixie sticks it makes so
much sense I think all of us now
especially third season I think all of
us now know how to suspend our disbelief
and contain our laughter when we're
doing the scenes enough so it's just
like yes that's exactly what happened no
doubt in my mind by the time we are done
with the winter finale mm-hmm the town
is quarantined yes and FP and Jughead
are just kind of on the outskirts yeah
where do we go from here I have no idea
I think they're on the outside of this
there clearly I have to start fashioning
a plan to get back in but not to spoil
too much but where we take off after
that is a time jump so it's not really
ever explained how they manage to break
back into Riverdale or if they even do
yeah if they just sort of camp and eat
Franks and beans on the outside of
Riverdale until the quarantine drop
got a love colfer always keeping it real
with us and I'm sending love to the
Riverdale publicist for letting me keep
in Cole's little line that we're getting
a teeny-tiny time jump in the next
episode
hooray for little Sweetwater spoilers
now what else is coming our way when
season 3 returns let's take a look at
this super special extended Riverdale
promo and find out I will say this once
and never speak of it again I've got a
job for you I know what I saw
revenge is a dish best served cold
[Music]
I just wanted some father-daughter time
do you think killing me will solve all
your problems
[Music]
then done okay first off I just want to
say that a lot of those scenes are not
gonna be seen in episode 309 they're in
future episodes I'm not telling you
which ones I'm referring to that I can
reveal that it's time for my three clues
about chapter 44 no exit ready let's go
number one a beloved character returns
but three are shunned number two there
are plenty of tasty things in LeBeau Nui
but you can't order this off the menu
and number three they say hell hath no
fury like a woman scorned but get ready
for double get it got it good now let's
move into my favorite part of these live
episodes of Sweetwater secrets answering
your questions without knowing what on
earth you've commented here we go
all right Wow first of all you guys have
already flooded my iPad right now I'm so
thrilled right now
gotcha glitter says ah Shoni and bug
head are back 'yeah yes they are back
and you know what i think i'm gonna give
you guys a little treat right now before
we move into the comments did you guys
think it was so cute in the last episode
when toni revealed that she's the big
spoon did you wonder how that came about
let's take a look at what Vanessa Morgan
had to tell me in this behind-the-scenes
secret to bit take a look this long
cuz I'm the big spoon I'm the big spoon
we have debates about this sometimes on
set when we're trying to like figure out
how to like lay and stuff like that and
we have like who's the big spoon above
up but I'm the big Speyer was that ad
libbed or was that in the script no this
is adlet like we're trying to like
literally figure out when we're laying
in bed we were having an argument me and
modelling over who should actually need
the big spoon and I think I won the
argument and I think that's what's
staying in the script yeah there you go
fun little behind-the-scenes tidbit for
you guys let me know what you think
about that right now Joanie lovers
Bella's life says loving the Cheryl
jacket
thank you very much girl I'm personally
loving the serpent tea it's my favorite
thing that I've worn in a little while
but you'll be seeing Cheryl rocking her
own jacket in tonight's episode so I
thought I'd bring it back Chloe
Hef says I'm looking forward to Veronica
and Reggie you know what they have been
growing on me I am excited to see where
they go in speaking with Charles on the
phone today he was so excited about
tonight's episode he's so excited for
all the fans to see it he's just a
sweetheart and I love the friendship
that he and cami share off screen I'm
not commenting on anything else um let's
see Veronica X Lodge said sorry for
spamming but we'd love to hear anything
about Varkey thanks Leon also super
excited to hear about Shoni Veronica
x-large I will have some barchi scoop
coming up for you guys in the next few
weeks
I spoke with KJ Appa about it I spoke
with Charles Milton about it I wouldn't
say that all hope is dead for VAR Chee
they are of course one of the core four
and the river dolt
writers love them but we we shall see
there's lots of ebbs and flows this
season we'll see how that goes um
Caitlin says does jelly bean come back I
think it's safe to assume that we will
not not be seeing jelly bean again this
season did you get that okay she's a
little sweetheart
Ireland rhadigan says die Hiram die
Hiram die die Hiram die I will say that
he once again receives the chop hiss in
my hisses and kisses in this week's
after-show so I think that I echo those
sentiments maybe not
I but go away go away Hyrum let's see
miss llama says I don't think Hyrum is
The Gargoyle King as he's friends with
the king and toasted to him at the end I
thought that was so weird that it was
higher I mean he was like toasting to
him is that a hallucination is he like
toasting to himself I don't know at this
point at this point I'm not sure if I
care anymore I feel like it keeps
getting dragged out it's like with a
black hood left season by the end I was
like it's so obviously it's Betty's dad
like come on so at this point like I
just feel like it always last like two
to three episodes too long take me to
the farm that's where we're going next
some shirt just I want to get to the
farm creepypasta says I hear that
there's a different universe episode
that will focus more on Cheryl Kevin
Josie and Reggie is that true it's not a
different universe episode it's an
episode that's being described as an
episode focusing on the other core four
but there's five of them so when I was
sitting with Ashley Marie on set we
decided to name the other core for the
fierce five so it'll be focusing on the
fierce five and I'm personally excited
about that one because Josie finally
gets some screen time and it's good
screen time Karen says I spy with my
little detective brown eyes Archie
aiming a gun towards Hiram sleeping in
the hospital any tea on that oh no
I'll say right now is that that extended
promo had way more than I thought that
they were gonna show you guys so good
job keep going through it frame by frame
because damn that was a big gift that
they gave you Queeny says I'm dying
those Shoni and bug head scenes look hot
there is a hot show a scene in tonight's
episode
get excited guys zippers volley does
barchi ever speak again without it
getting awkward
I feel like Archie has to come back for
them to actually speak so I can't even
speak to that
vd says aw I was looking forward to
getting all those scenes in one episode
that would be epic plus Shoni declares
love to each other in this episode as
per what Roberto said on his Instagram
I think Roberto said that on his
Instagram he he might have alluded to
something but he did not specifically
say that a lot of folks are getting
excited to see Kelly Ripa I was really
excited to see her for a little bit in
that episode or in that teaser and her
episode is going to be a noir episode
and as you guys already know she is
playing Hiram's mistress I don't know
how I feel about him getting a mistress
but considering it is his real-life wife
I'm okay with that
I will be giving you guys an interview
with Cole Sprouse talking about working
with Kelly Ripa but he said he had a
blast
sharing scenes with her we're gonna take
a couple more questions oh we're doing
really good on time so I'm gonna keep
going let's see Molly Bruton says she
has a theory I definitely think that the
blossoms have something to do with Gigi
especially because of the red paladin I
reckon Jason was the original red
palette and just saying I've been seeing
this theory a lot in the Sweetwater
comments which by the way you guys left
over a thousand on our last episode so I
was really excited about that made me
look real cool but I've been seeing a
lot that Jason could be tied to
Griffin's and gargoyles that would be so
epic if it really like tied back to the
pilot I think I've spoke about this
before do I think that it's actually
gonna go that far back and have these
really cool connections that we've all
of it together no because I just think
that that would be super great and I
don't think that we're gonna be I don't
think we're gonna get that big of a
reward but I do like the idea that it
might have come from
Penelope blossom I don't know I just I'm
worried that we're getting so much
Griffins and gargoyles in this season
and that we're not gonna get as big of a
payoff as we deserve because we've been
watching it this whole time um the
Simpson show says well Cheryl say out
loud that she is a lesbian not that what
I've seen but also why does she need to
say that I think it's clear that Cheryl
and Tony have a really great
relationship and whatever her sexual
orientation is is I'm enjoying watching
it on scene on screen I think that
Cheryl has found someone
who cares about her and that she can
actually share a sweet life with so I'm
really happy about that and I just
realized I said sweet life and of course
now I'm thinking about coal but I I just
like the fact that sure I was happy I
think she deserves that she's been
through enough she's lost a lot of
people on her life let her be happy
Caitlyn Joan says I think there's gonna
be a special bond between Cheryl and
jelly bean she has a slingshot Cheryl
does archery it would be really great to
see another softness to Cheryl I think
that they are both great little badasses
I personally before I see jellybean
share scenes with Cheryl I want more
jellybeans and FP scenes jelly bean and
Jughead scenes I want to see jelly bean
and Betty meat basically let's just have
the whole show let's get Joey being a
spin a spin-off how it actually be
pretty great Ruby says what's wrong with
penny I don't know what's wrong with
penny I think Gladys killed her
I probably not because that would be too
satisfying and I'm sure she'll will see
her pop up again because the actress who
plays penny is sensational so I'm sure
we'll see here again but I don't know if
there's anything wrong with penny I
think that Gladys took care of that for
us that was great they're going nuts for
Morra barchi scoop they want the tea Oh
Bart she fans
good to see you again nothing for you as
of this moment there is just watch
tonight's episode it's nothing too crazy
but just just watch it tonight's episode
there's a nice callback to the pilot
that I think that you guys will enjoy
let's see we're still getting in so many
comments right now I've gone through so
many okay okay
Alisha Alisha hitching says so was the
quarantine
Hiram's idea so he can make Riverdale
into a real life G&G board that's cool
that's a great theory that I haven't
seen before I don't know how it would be
a real life G&G board because no one
really seems to know how she going to do
works but I will say that if you are
hoping to get answers about the
quarantine in tonight's episode you
might still be hoping because I know I
sure AM Veronica
wants to know you kind of gave away the
Archies back because in the interview
with KJ was in his jacket hahaha
actually KJ was just in his jacket
because he was cold that day and that
was just something for him to put on so
hahaha that was just in his trailer
riverdale blue and gold I had a theory
about Poli when she was at the sisters
she was playing G M G and that's why
when she got out of the sister she went
directly to the farm as it was sort of a
quest for her that's a great theory
paulie's in tonight's episode
as well as the return of Evelyn ever and
ever now know about you guys but
Evelyn's really been growing on me I
like her I know I'm not supposed to
trust her but like I've said before I
like to actress I'm her little buggy
eyes and I think that she is she plays a
perfect balance of like mysterious and
creepy really well but I love that
theory about Paulie and we definitely do
see Paulie talking about the farm and
her connection to the sisters of quiet
mercy so good eyes you we're gonna just
take two more questions
vt says I didn't want penny to die she
deserves a more gruesome death who says
it's not gruesome just cuz we didn't see
it something tells me that Gladys likes
slow burns I have a feeling that she
sliced her up real good yeah and then a
lot of folks are asking for phallus they
want the tea I want the phallus tea too
it has been way too long since we've got
a good FP in Alice scene Alice isn't
tonight's episode FP is in tonight's
episode that's all I'll say about that
there's nothing to get too excited about
for tonight's episode but I love me some
phallus I need if they want to really
play up the FP and Gladys situation and
then the love triangle with with phallus
I need more phallus for it to be more
interesting does that make sense like
you can't throw and Gladys into the
situation expect all of us to just be
like okay like I need to really get that
like I'm conflicted right now that's
what I want basically that's just a long
way of me saying give me that fallacy
last one Kaitlyn says all right Kaitlyn
I'm gonna see if I can make sense of
this
imagine if baby tooth is Charles oh oh
imagine if baby tooth is Charles F P
analysis son this is completely
irrelevant but you said Polly's so oh
well I totally forgot about baby tooth
that was a random one-off character and
Archie's Fight Club episode we're not
gonna end it on that note and I don't
think that that's I don't think that's
Charles all right one more question and
then we are going to wrap it up guys
let's see let's see if we can find a
really good one Oh Simon good one well
Tony topes kick any ass I quess I'm
sorry that was a comment here's what
I'll say about Tony something really big
happens in tonight's episode and you
guys need to tune into the after jokes I
have a really long and really great
sit-down with Vanessa Morgan really
talking about the repercussions of
tonight's episode and a little bit of
Tony's headspace as we move forward
it really does after you watch this
episode and hear what vanessa has to say
it really changes the way I think that
you're gonna look at Tony moving forward
that you're gonna look at Cheryl
antonius relationship it's a pretty big
bombshell that happens cheryl pun
intended
i hope that we get to see tony kick some
ass in the future it's been a lot a long
time since we saw that and i think she
deserves more so that's what i'm gonna
say and I think this is a good place to
stop thank you river babes so much for
joining me for this live preview episode
and if you're watching this and you miss
the live portion
no worries be sure to follow me on
Twitter to find out when we're going
live because it's gonna start happening
a lot more often I'm gonna try and make
these live preview episodes on
Wednesdays a weekly thing tell me if you
enjoy them or if you like our other pre
produced previews tell me in the
comments cuz I'll check with that and
then check back with me after you watch
episode 309 chapter 44 no exit for
exclusive interviews like I said with
Vanessa Morgan and one with KJ app' that
you definitely don't want to miss but
for now please give this video a like
hit subscribe and then
down to the comments to see if you can
crack my three clues I've missed you
ribs so much and I'm so excited to
continue on our crazy Riverdale journey
together on Sweetwater secrets
[Music]
you